the second sighting of a suspected
Chinese surveillance balloon late Friday
the Pentagon confirmed its monitoring
reports of a balloon over Latin America
as a first balloon still floats over the
U.S overnight China's foreign Ministry
accused some U.S politicians and media
of using the balloon sightings as
pretext to smear China Secretary of
State Anthony blinken who postponed his
high-stakes trip to Beijing called
China's act unacceptable and
irresponsible Christina raffini is in
Washington with the very latest
Christina good morning
good morning Dana well as far as the
balloon over the U.S American officials
say they've disabled its ability to
collect intelligence but it's still
making people a bit uneasy as it makes
its way across the country with some
Republican lawmakers saying the U.S
should shoot it down
it's a bird it's a plane no it's an
ongoing diplomatic incident and we got
that balloon inside
the Pentagon says it won't give live
updates as to where the balloon is the
public certainly has the ability to look
up in the sky and and see where the
balloon is except to say it's currently
floating somewhere above the middle of
the country there were sightings Friday
over Kansas and Missouri military
commanders have assessed that there is
no physical or military threat to people
on the ground in an uncharacteristically
contrite statement the Chinese
government said it regrets the
unintended entry of a weather balloon
into U.S airspace the U.S says it's not
buying it we're confident this is a
Chinese surveillance balloon yesterday
Secretary of State Anthony blinken
canceled meetings with his counterpart
in Beijing hours before takeoff the
prc's decision to take this action on
the even by planned visit is detrimental
to the substantive discussions that we
were prepared to have
[Music]
are you President Biden didn't respond
to questions about the balloon Friday
but the White House says he was briefed
on the topic earlier this week and that
the military advised against shooting it
down it was the strong recommendation
not to take kinetic action because of
the risk to safety and and security of
the people on the military on the ground
the Pentagon says the payload underneath
the inflatable including solar panels
and heavy equipment is about the size of
three city buses the balloon first came
to the Public's attention over Montana
home to several U.S nuclear missile
bases they could have shot that balloon
down Montana's Republican senator Steve
daines the biggest risk might have been
hitting a cow a prairie dog or an
antelope that was their moment
secretary blinken said he told his
Chinese counterpart that he wants to try
to reschedule the talks for a time when
they don't have this issue hanging over
their heads as for when that will be
Jeff it's still up in the air
okay Christina thank you very much